[Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  is  we do not go anywhere near the surface  everything good is above the surface  walking  air the sky clouds the sun  whoa don't look at it just kidding  definitely look at it  have you ever gone to the human town  i'm yeah of an expert  [Music]  we underdogs have to look out for each  other what's under the dogs  this is my dad why do you think he kills  with those anything that swims  your life is so much cooler than mine  there's a million things you think you  can't do  all you need is a chance to try  something  [Music]  can you still hear him nope just you  good  now hang on  what's wrong with you stupido you do it  now just say the thing  what's wrong with you stupido  [Music]  foreign